as Cara was a healthy and Active Child
this was a few months before her fourth
birthday she loved to read and sing but
most of all she loved to skate in early
October her mother says she gave her
child flu medicine because she had a
cough the next day she was admitted to
hospital vomiting and unable to urinate
on Saturday night the doctor called me
they said my daughter is critical all
her organs are damaged her brain heart
liver and eyes on Sunday morning she had
heart failure and she died in my lap
she's just one of more than a hundred
children in Indonesia who have died in
recent months from acute kidney injury
after being given medicinal syrup
earlier this month the World Health
Organization issued a warning after
cough syrup in The Gambia was also
linked to the deaths of nearly 70
children most of the acute kidney injury
cases this year involve children under
the age of
drug agency is investigating and
meanwhile some medicines have been
pulled off Pharmacy shelves
in some cities police conducted checks
to ensure compliance with the rule
but say the real number of fatalities is
likely to be higher due to
under-reporting
it is fairly new condition
we never had a lot of children with
intoxication before if in the Central
Hospital is it still confusing yeah so
how in the rural area
the health Ministry says it will
strengthen controls in the future
says there must be accountability
the government needs to investigate this
intensively and come up with Solutions I
don't want any mother to feel what I'm
feeling right now I've lost my baby
she has started to donate some of her
daughter's things but her roller skates
are still here at the front of the house
a reminder of the joy she brought to
this home that was suddenly taken away
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Jakarta
well joining us now to talk more about
this is Dickie budeman researcher in
global Health security at Griffiths
University joins us from Bandung
Indonesia thank you for being with us
this is a really a heartbreaking story
but also one filled with anger that this
was allowed to happen
yeah this is uh to know the case the
first case that take in January 2000 and
I mean this year and also then uh wh
also released the awareness about about
this issue in early of uh October so we
can see from in term of the global
Health security how poor and also how
little uh
ill prepare for our uh uh Global Health
security respond in terms of medicine
and for the safety product and then now
we see in not only in in Gambia the
first case appear and also then some in
India but then now Indonesia has the
highest number uh not only in terms of
uh the the victim but also uh the
probability the total cases which is
underreported when we know Indonesia has
a huge population also and also many
islands and the
literacy of health is also another
problem because then majority of these
patients probably just among community
and they don't know and then they didn't
go to the health services and I agree
and also strongly advise that
governments should take this uh as the
outbreak National status because then
they have to responsible to do not only
to cure by imported the antidote to to
the patient but also to find the cases
among the community and Screen them and
also support the uh unvulnerable one who
has you know limited access a limited
Financial resource to go to the hospital
to get the treatment that's the useful
of these outbreak National status to
support not only Community but also the
local this the COS these limited access
and what sort of symptoms should parents
be looking for to detect this early and
and be in a position to do something
about it
yeah so the in the first in first time
that I uh arise the awareness that at
least the local Health provisional
should aware that if there is some uh
children who has a symptom of unable to
uh you urinate or pee especially under
you know five years old uh years old so
that's a main symptom that we have to
take this very seriously and of course
then the other symptom that appear from
the uh the the symptom so far the diary
and also for me so those three main
symptoms should be the the first uh the
first way we can uh screen and also to
take the the at the early stage of the
case because that very important because
these a good kidney failure the respawn
is depend on how fast we found the the
the the the the the cases and also then
it's not only if yes I appreciate that
the government now already banned the
several number of the medicines
especially but that's not uh enough
because we know Indonesia is again uh a
little illiteracy but the medicine is
also our problem and not necessarily uh
in let's say in remote island they know
about this and also we have also to find
another solution because covering and
also flow in Indonesia is very common so
again we have to also give another
solution for them in some of this
medication then again uh I I always say
in terms of this situation we have to do
our best to support especially not only
in Java because again the majority cases
now now a support that or contribute
from Java Island but it doesn't mean out
of uh Java Island there is no case
because again the government should uh
guarantee the security of the the
medicine in in all Indonesia we're gonna
have to leave it there but uh I really
appreciate your your thoughts on what is
a very important story uh thanks very
much for being with us thank you
bootyman
thank you for having me